عربه حركه النهضه عن رفضها لاستمرار غلق
مقرها المركز ومقرها في المحافظات بدواعي
استمرار عمليات التفتيش
واعتبرت ان استمرار هذه العمليات طيله
اكثر من شهر هو منع مقنع للنشاط السياسي
للحركه وبانه تعدي على حقوق حزب قانوني
وندد بيان للمكتب التنفيذي للحركه بما
وصفه الهجمه الاعلاميه التي تستهدف الحركه
وقادتها عبر تشويههم على حد وصف البيع
في تونس ايضا قال رئيس جمعيه القضاه
التونسيين انس الحمادي ان وزاره العدل
باتت تتدخل في العديد
من التي لم تقتصر على القضاه فحسب بل على
مستوى الاعلاميين الذين يتم تتبعهم اضافه
الى النقابيين والسياسيين والمدونين وعموم
المواطنين وفق تعبيره وشدد الحمادي في
افتتاح اجتماع المجلس الوطني للجمعيه
اليوم ان القضاء بات تابعه لسلطه
التنفيذيه بعد تسليط سيف الاعفاءات حسب
قوله
وزاره العدد تتدخل مباشره عن طريق
التعليمات في عديد الملفات وشاهدنا هذايا
مش على مستوى القضاه فقط شاهدناه حتى على
مستوى الساده الاعلاميين اللي مثل صوت
الحر في وسائل الاعلام اللي تعرضوا الى
التتبعات الجزائيه شفنا النقابيين شفنا
السياسيين شفنا
مدونين شفنا عموم المواطنين كانوا معناها
محل استهداف كل صوت حر كان محل استهداف من
هذه الوضعيه الان القضاء الان تابع
بالتمامه والكمال للسلطه التنفيذيه لان
القضاه بعد سيف الاعفاءات وبعد مجزره
الاعفاءات يعملون تحت التهديد القضاه
يعملون تحت الخوف والترهيب اليومي من
وزاره العدل